Traduttore: Caterina Iacomelli
Revisore: Valentina Ferreri
Come identifichiamo noi una persona di successo?
Mi sono fatta questa domanda
venendo a Matera,
perché ho pensato di salire su questo palco
e parlare di qualcosa che nessuno conosce.
Quindi mi sto confrontando
con una piattaforma sulla quale
sono saliti architetti, matematici,
scrittori, giornalisti,
persone che hanno da dire qualcosa.
E quindi, nonostante la stazza,
mi sono sentita una nanetta fra giganti.
Ho pensato, come posso calcare lo stesso
palcoscenico di queste persone di talento?
Poi mi sono resa conto che con loro
condivido la passione e l'amore
per il lavoro che faccio e l'entusiasmo
che ci metto ogni volta che mi confronto
con un cliente. Perciò ho detto: "Sì,
in fondo, posso parlare anch'io al TEDx"
Il Feng Shui purtroppo è un argomento
che è poco noto
quindi non vi potrò spiegare
questa disciplina in pochi minuti,
perché è veramente molto complessa.
Ha le sue radici nella Cina millenaria
quindi immaginate che alla base
ci sono filosofie importantissime
tra le quali la filosofia dei 5 elementi,
lo Yin e Yang, l'almanacco lunare,
quindi nel Feng Shui
convergono tante cose.
In realtà è uno strumento di
decodifica delle percezioni sottili.
Immaginate di entrare in uno spazio nuovo,
mentre andate a trovare un amico
che ha cambiato casa. Entrate in una casa
che non conoscete
e quindi avrete il dubbio di uno spazio
nuovo. Vi troverete a contatto
con qualcosa di nuovo. Ecco, immaginate
di entrare in questa casa qui.
Questa è la casa di un mio intervento
a Milano.
Voi avrete sentito qualcosa, magari
si tratta di una sensazione sgradevole,
perché quella casa non vi piace.
Oppure una sensazione gradevole.
Questa capacità di ascolto è fondamentale,
è alla base della sopravvivenza,
quindi state facendo Feng Shui
senza saperlo. Bravissimi!
Ora, è chiaro che non è così semplice però
attraverso il lavoro, con il Feng Shui
si può capire cosa c'è che non va
nella nostra vita,
se ancora non ce ne siamo
resi conto da soli.
Questa casa appartiene ad un uomo
sulla cinquantina
fiscalista di un'azienda petrolifera
in Congo.
Era una persona di successo, considerando
che aveva la macchina con autista,
un attico con vista favolosa,
stipendio a 4 zeri.
Quindi sicuramente non stava male,
ma ha cominciato ad avere un certo disagio
e a non sopportare più la vita
che stava facendo
e diciamo che ha cominciato anche ad
ammalarsi fisicamente.
Ascoltando questa sensazione non positiva,
lui si è fermato e ha voluto dare ascolto
a quello che non andava bene.
Allora ha smesso, si è trasferito a Milano
e si è fermato in attesa di capire
cosa fare.
Poi, tramite conoscenze, mi ha contattato
e abbiamo lavorato insieme.
Lui è stato bravo, fino a un certo punto
ha lavorato da solo
a capire che qualcosa non andava.
In casa sua ho spostato il tavolo.
Vedete dalla foto? Il tavolo prima era
in mezzo alla stanza
adesso invece è appoggiato alla parete.
La colonna rossa serve per smuovere
le situazioni. E adesso è uno chef vegano.
Quindi chiaramente ha fatto
una rivoluzione totale.
Ha cambiato lavoro, vita,
eppure oggi si sente soddisfatto e felice.
È sano, quindi, dal mio punto di vista,
è una persona di successo.
Chiaramente lui è stato bravo,
perché ha dato spazio al movimento
al moto interiore che lo ha portato a vedere
che dentro di sé qualcosa non funzionava.
E in effetti il movimento è il cardine
del significato di questi due ideogrammi
che sono il vento e l'acqua
che in natura, più degli altri,
rendono manifesta questa capacità
di muoversi delle cose.
È vero che si muovono anche i ghiacciai
anche le montagne, la terra si muove,
però il vento e l'acqua sono associati
anche alla vita.
Immaginate una terra senza vento:
il polline non potrebbe spostarsi,
quindi non ci sarebbero fiori né frutti.
Immaginate una terra senz'acqua:
noi non potremmo esistere.
Insieme al movimento c'è anche la vita.
Cosa succede quando noi ci fermiamo
per paura, per ansia?
Ci blocchiamo, ci irrigidiamo
e alla fine ci spezziamo.
Quindi nel Feng Shui il lavoro
consiste soprattutto nel rimettere in moto
il flusso di energie nella casa,
ma soprattutto nella nostra vita.
Quindi, facendo questo lavoro,
le persone lavorano su se stesse
ed iniziano un percorso di consapevolezza.
Io ho scelto quest'immagine qua,
perché rappresenta una strada
d'inizio di un percorso.
Una strada nel bosco.
Mi ha ricordato vagamente Dante,
anche se ovviamente non possiamo
paragonarci al sommo poeta.
Però mi ha ricordato la fatica che si fa
nell'affrontare se stessi.
É un vero lavoro.
Ai miei clienti chiedo un atto di
coraggio, non un atto di fede,
perché non bisogna credere nel Feng Shui,
ma un atto di coraggio sì.
Perché le persone devono abbandonare
l'attaccamento a quelle false sicurezze
e lasciarsi andare, per scoprire
i veri talenti, i veri tesori
che ci sono dentro di noi. E dare ascolto
a quella voce che è solo il movimento
dell'anima che vuole crescere, avanzare,
si vuole espandere.
Quindi nel momento in cui qualcuno
mi chiama e mi chiede aiuto
io non faccio altro che fargli da specchio
e attraverso l'analisi della sua carta
natale con l'oroscopo cinese
e della struttura della casa rendo
evidenti le cose che dovrebbe aggiustare,
i temi su cui lavorare, perché magari
non è stato facile per questa persona
rendersene conto da solo.
E quindi per me la persona di successo
è questa, cioè quella che è stata capace
di ritornare a riscoprire
non il bambino interiore,
ma proprio il bambino.
Il bambino che noi eravamo e che era puro,
entusiasta, gioioso,
capace di affrontare la realtà senza paura
perché la paura è solo un'idea.
Invece dobbiamo avere fiducia
nelle nostre capacità, andare avanti,
niente è impossibile per quelli
che ci credono e che si mettono in moto.
Per gli altri, purtroppo,
li lasciamo alle nostre spalle.
Grazie.